thank you
[Applause]
oh look at you look at all of you okay
all right that's enough that's enough
calm down put your clothes back on it's
Friday so you know what that means let's
welcome tonight's guests he gets his
haircut at the Lego factory co-host of
the clay Travis and Buck Sexton show
Mark Sexton
[Applause]
he hails from San Francisco which means
he loves the smell of urine actor in
comedian Scott caparo
[Applause]
she cheered at the end of Old Yeller Fox
News contributor Kat tip
[Applause]
and psychics need a GPS to read his palm
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
all right
before we get to some news stories let's
do this
Greg's leftovers
yeah leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading them so if they
suck we'll put Joe Mackey in a barrel
and send him over Niagara Falls
here we go
applauding Joe Mackey's death
I like this audience James Comer says
that Joe Biden as vice president
corresponded with Hunter Biden using the
pseudonym Robert L Peters I guess that's
better than his current fake name
president
yeah I know I know this week Biden told
kids visiting the White House quote I
know some really great ice cream places
around here and daddy owes you
that's not the joke it's not that's real
he added that if they notice any
children's hair in the desert that's
just his favorite topping
to remove carbon from the atmosphere the
Biden Administration is funding projects
that will use giant vacuums to suck it
up
they're also funding a project that will
use a drug addict to snort it
[Applause]
I love him
oh
Tampa Bay Rays star player wander Franco
that's his name wander Franco
this is hard it's being investigated
amid rumors that he may be dating a 14
year old girl
don't judge
Scouts say they're not surprised because
he was very successful in the minors
humor cats
minor leagues in the major leagues
according to a new study erectile
dysfunction cases in the U.S have
doubled and experts believe they figured
out the cause
it writes itself
according to a letter Obama reportedly
sent to a former girlfriend in 1982 he
imagined making love to men daily
prompting Michelle Obama to reply I
haven't made love to one in decades
gratuitous
but Obama imagining making love to men
well I guess that explains this
all right
oh like you could do better
you could but anyway Republican
candidates descended on the Iowa State
Fair last week to mingle with the people
and load up on Carnival Food former New
Jersey Governor Chris Christie arrived
two weeks early
[Applause]
it's because he's fat I know
happy birthday to Robert Redford who
turned 87 today and to his hairpiece
which turned 42.
a male power lifter broke women's
records in the Western Canadian
championship women are beginning to lose
count of how many sports records are
broken by men because it's happening a
lot and they're terrible at Counting
what
yes that's what a sexist would say
you're learning see this is all about
education educating people scientists
say men are more likely to say I love
you first
the research also revealed women are
more likely to say get away from me nerd
that's cute a stomach churning video
went viral showing a bull Goring a
Spanish Matador in his rectum
but in the Bull's defense The Matador
did say he was horny
so bad
I'm ashamed
during a recent trip in China treasury
secretary Janet Yellen confessed that
she ate hallucinogenic mushrooms at a
restaurant
and here we thought the only one who ate
mushrooms was her Barber
earlier this week there was a near
collision at the Boston airport between
Jets from American and Spirit Air which
proves not even the pilots want to fly
spirit
and finally in San Francisco driverless
cars are reportedly causing traffic to
get backed up if only the homeless were
that backed up
poop joke
little
transient excrement humor
all right to the news should trans
players switch to Checkers even if they
cut off their
peckers
probably didn't need to say that but the
international Chess Federation the only
organization dorkier than the Star Trek
Federation says it will abolish the
women's titles that a female player has
earned if she becomes a he this of
course is Earth shattering news to the
one nerd who follows International chess
in addition trans women are banned from
competing in women's events eliminating
the slight advantage of moving ponds
with their giant hands
don't cry Dylan Mulvaney you'll always
have beer pong
and a penis
now they're making the change because
women's titles are considered less
valuable than men's so a so-called woman
Grandmaster wouldn't be transferred to a
general Grandmaster even though you'd
save award money by only paying her 70
cents on the dollar
a sexist would say
see
now I admit I don't know much about the
fascinating and time-honored game of
chess although you should hear me yell
you sank my battleship
but why are there men's and women's
divisions at all perhaps it's to prevent
those tournaments from becoming orgies
but it's but it's not like a physical
sport where biological males have an
innate Advantage I think it's weird that
there aren't more women in chess I mean
there are many successful women
everywhere including high levels of
government
[Music]
after all being great at chess doesn't
call for muscle mass just look at the
men
puny runs instead it requires logic
patience and abstract thinking but if
they add parallel parking you broads are
doomed
wow yet another sexist would say all
right
how you doing there champ I'm good
man how are you uh you don't care I'm
going on vacation this is my last thing
before I go to Scotland for a week so
I'll be wearing a kilt and getting drunk
every day I wish I'd ask that question
you know Scott
do you how do you feel about Chess this
is kind of an interesting dilemma here
they're coming in it from a different
angle is it going to shock you to know
the guy who has boat shoes in four
different colors took chess lessons as a
kid that's actually true yeah I know
that's actually real I took chess
lessons as a kid for a little while it
was it was fun and then then I hit uh
puberty and then it got you know I was
interested in other things so I spent
less time playing chess that's when you
got the station wagon Otherwise Known
otherwise known as a shagging wagon
right paneled sides I will have you know
that is now a classic car and it's
actually far more valuable than people
would have anticipated imagine if you
had sex in it
you know
but it's coming on Buck
I'm gonna punch your mother in the mouth
when we leave
or do you think there's a biological
differences in playing chess well this
is uh there's no answer that's going to
make people happy with this other than
you should just open up this to men and
women playing and see what happens I
mean the only way you could say there's
a biological Advantage would be to go
the Larry Summers Harvard route you
remember that the president of Harvard
yeah who's like maybe we have just
theoretically fewer women getting Fields
medals in mathematics because of some
and it that was one of the original yeah
cancellations destroy the guy was the
treasury secretary he had a great role
in the uh social network so yeah yeah
and then he was gone because he so you
just can't but answer that well how you
can I've said it before and I will do it
again for all of you I think that men
are better than women at chess but
that's because women are more
emotionally intelligent than men are
which means that they're far less likely
to have the kind of social life that
would force them to resort to
competitive chess
uh no because even if you're playing
competitive chess as a woman you
probably have at least some friends
right yeah so you're using some of your
brain to form meaningful emotional
connections which is great but also is
probably not an advantage in a robot
brain sport like chess but people only
care about women in chess if they're hot
like that TV show on Netflix yes exactly
she was completely delicious so people
they gave a poo but about most chests
the guys look like they crawled out from
under a rock 20 years ago so nobody
cares yeah and by the way did you know
that that Netflix show was fiction right
I thought it was real when I was
watching it that there was this amazing
female chess player that like could
Envision these things then somebody told
me it was made up but I felt like of
course it's made up so you had to throw
the glove away that you wore when you
were watching it yes
but no you sound really a sport people
call it a sport but it's not if you
don't shave your legs it's not
competitive
did you ever play chess no I had a
social life as a kid yeah I'm not Lonely
no
exactly yeah wow you know we're losing
the uh chess playing audience right now
you're not they don't you're not no I I
was with cat until she said emotional
intelligence and I was like what
chess maybe for the chest is something
that in football we played a lot and
weightlifting we used to do this
activity at the end when you were
exhausted you had to play speed chess
because that's what makes you when
you're most exhausted makes you think
more chess I play chess with my
daughters because I want them always
thinking two moves ahead and what they
did was with this was brilliant with all
the sports that are having all the
problems with transgender women invading
what they did was amazing they didn't
say you couldn't play they just said
we're going to research it and figure it
out it's going to take us about I don't
know two years and then we'll let you
know that's chess that's Brilliance they
they LeapFrog the whole problem because
you can't yell at somebody for
researching it they're like I'm gonna
read the instructions and when we figure
it out we'll get back to you that's
brilliant so they avoided the problem
without actually having to solve the
problem and on top of that if you switch
you lose
right what it really comes down to what
this whole thing has been is mediocre
biological men who decide to claim their
women to be what to get attention and be
successful because they want to beat
women in sports because the way things
worked out physically men are stronger
than women okay women tend to be smarter
but it doesn't always translate over to
chess because chess is more confined
it's one move in one moment under a
short amount of time so they don't know
if there's a difference or not plus as
cat said most women aren't interested in
chess usually some for some reason it
was very man's game so and now women are
starting to get involved in it so
they're kind of behind but again it goes
back to the thing when you take away the
opportunity
without getting in their face about it
there's no complaints there's no there's
no one not that there's going to be I
don't think there's a huge amount of
transgender women chess players marching
outside of Fox right now demanding equal
play oh that would be amazing I'd love
to watch that it's really tough this
whole thing for gay men like my husband
and I the male female thing yeah because
you know my husband's stronger but I
have the money so it's hard to decide
and I can't be a woman because I'm a
comedian so
[Laughter]
and I can't be a pedophile because I
hate children
and they laugh
that's not even the worst jokes
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else